all societies most societies and most
nations are built off a core
family nuclear family structure okay the
west seems to be straying more away from
a nuclear family structure and so
if the men are building their society
right generally men build societies
women nurture what's in the society
so if the men are building the society
and women are nurturing what's in
society and like i said the women aren't
right and we need a nuclear family
structure yet and still this
this society teaches women to be
independent you don't need a man you can
do it all by yourself okay that is going
to affect the moral fabric of the
society in which we live in but if you
make the point about women making bad
choices about partners if they stop
making those choices then they're wrong
for making the choices not to be with
partners who are going to be horrible to
them wait because it's a way to say that
again so so because of feminine sexual
liberation
they don't need a man they become
independent that's the thing yes but
it's come from a space where women make
choices to be with the wrong men so they
decide to make different choices to be
independent to not pursue those options
so then what's what's the right choice
so you're saying that they made that
choice because of
so so in in this situation where monroe
made the decision to be with those
toxic just as an example not her
specifically but made that choice to be
in those toxic relationships and and now
we're on the other side where women are
choosing to be independent choosing not
to be in those toxic relationships
rather choosing to support themselves
then rely on someone who's going to
ultimately harm her
well she
yeah why are you acting like those are
the only two options like
why is that why are the only two why are
the only two options pick a bad guy or
be by yourself because some people don't
actually have a choice
i think i think
a lot of women so when i think about my
grandma or
you know the men that she was dating
whatever
um
at that time you didn't really have a
job if you're a woman it wasn't really
you basically forced not to basically
and then the men that came to you were
your options right she had two options
both were not very nice men and once you
get into a relationship you can get you
can fall in love with a narcissist and
you could be amazing and then you marry
them and then they just
every single day and without any
financial freedom or independence you
can't leave
right so in this society it's like look
you could leave today you could get a
job yeah i mean just because you don't
like your options you could get a job in
the past but what you're saying is with
a nuclear family the woman stays home
she doesn't go to work she's not
independent that's kind of what i'm
hearing maybe that's not what you meant
but if a woman can't be financially
independent and free then
some people don't actually have that
choice in being able to leave a violent
relationship i'm not saying girls can't
be financially independent like they
could they can go be financially
independent but what i'm saying it's not
conducive for families right so like
kids it's better for a thumb to have a
mom and a dad in the hall right that's
incredibly hard to normal or a
heteronormative as well right there's so
many sorry what's heter i don't know
sorry as in like um straight from
straight couples right there there's so
many different family dynamics that can
like supportively and genuinely raise
the kids so so i will say on this show
we try to stick to the rule rather than
the exception and that's not the
majority i'll get to the rule i'll get
to the rule
63 of youth suicides yeah are from
single mother homes 90 of homelessness
and runaway children are from singapore
you can't put that on the mother 85 of
children who show behavioral disorders
are from single mother homes 80 of
rapists with anger problems are from
single mother homes seventy one percent
of high high school dropouts are from
single mother homes seventy percent of
youths in operated institutions are from
single mother homes eighty percent of
all the youths are in prison are from
single mother homes
you guys guys why is your immediate
reaction you're blaming the woman when
he's just reading a stat because i think
wait where this conversation was going
was like you know what women need to
behave and women need to act correctly
and then life would be sweet
they've been more nuclear families like
that's not the case there's a lot of
relationships that don't work and for a
lot of women the best situation they can
like they can give to their child to say
i'm going to leave this man okay you
know what i'm saying i'm saying
the man leaves the man
there's nowhere to be seen he's
different statistically that's not true
that's not true women leave 70 to 80 of
the time i'm pretty sure now it's 80 and
if you're college educated it's 90 so
women are the ones leaving
and and the other thing is like the
reason the reason i would put it on the
woman is because you pick who you have a
baby with
so so
yeah
okay okay so we're we're in the uk now
right and abortion's legal up to six
months yeah you pick who you have a baby
with
you're you you get an out but what if
you have a baby with someone believing
that they're a genuine person that
they're going to step up and then they
choose in my experience that's the
exception it's not the rule because what
i see is girls see the red flags early
on they keep dating him
and then it goes poorly and they're
crying later but it's like you saw the
10 million red flags before you had the
kids
so many different things involved in not
seeing red flags there are so many
different mental health issues there's
so many different societies there's so
many excuses it's not yes yes there's
excuse but there's a reason for it
there's a reason that's an excuse
it doesn't mean it's not justified sound
like you have a lot of excuses for women
i don't have excuses for women i
what women have been through to me is
just taking care of you
i think the conversation is like you're
trying to say it's everything's really
black and white yeah this is the reason
why women leave
all the time like they're so
relationships are so complex that
looking at a stat you can't be like okay
well it's women's fault they need to
behave yeah but the results is what
matters
what matters is not your feelings what
matters is the results at the end of the
day and so if the results are a certain
percentage of women 80 are leaving
marriages your feelings don't come into
the situation because what's happening
is because everyone's going to have
different feelings right
this woman said it was because that
reason that woman said it because of
that reason it was because of this but
at the end of the day the result is it's
eighty percent of women leaving marriage
and at the end and at the end and at the
end of the day it's the kids who suffer
because you're putting your feelings
above the kids and this is i'm taking
out exceptions like abuse outside
outside of abuse you're putting your
your feelings above the children do you
not think if men behave better women
would stay
because women and now you know you have
to be responsible you have to get a job
but also you have to do the domestic
labor you have to do the emotional labor
men
in today's society like
yeah you have to get a job and you have
to like isn't that healthy
you had a bit sexist yeah but like yeah
but like
but i don't understand why it's okay to
be openly sexist against men but it's
not sad because what has been said if
women just behaved better that it would
be better because
that's that's the whole that's the whole
stream
i was only saying that to like combat
saying oh it's the women's fault what
about
we're not saying men could be a better
husband and could help around the house
more the fact that men help around the
house when it's their house as well like
that's literally what it's called like
there is a disparity with the amount of
labor that women do and that men do yeah
but
men make more money statistically so you
could just say the men contribute more
yeah men provide value like if a dude's
paying my rent he's not doing [ __ ] he's
not doing [ __ ] around the
house yeah but women also work so like
they're also doing a nine to five like
maybe
so like what i'm saying statistically
men make more money i just so go ahead i
just wanted to ask all your statistics
and your percentages all of that where
did you find it is it in the uk is it in
the u.s uk and us
there's a little bit of a disparity
between the uk and u.s specifically when
it comes to divorce is 64 in the uk and
it's 80 in and
who carried out
um the government the government studies
how many women 100 women and then ask
them about their life so do you